sponsored by WB games hey there folks
and welcome to inside lego dimensions a
new series sponsored by WB games in
which I Chris waters of GameSpot and him
Aaron Hanson of game drops that's me
we're gonna talk about lego dimensions
and explore all the strange and
wonderful ways it's kind of like the
Lego games we play before but also way
different from the Lego games you play
we are taking on in this episode the
starter pack this is the thing that gets
you going with lego dimensions so let's
take a look first up you jump right in
and you see this dramatic cutscene and
then you expect
alright cool I got queued up from this
guy gonna jump right in and play the
game but no Lego dimensions a big part
of the game is building Legos and so
it's up to us to build this deep way
structure that's gonna sort of immerse
us in the lego situation in real life
let's do it now and voila the toy pad
and the Gateway all constructed in all
of its otherworldly glory I love it it
glows it's blue we've got wild style on
the toy pad now but she needs some
companions so to fire that up let's jump
into one of the early levels and see
what this bad boy can do let's do it
alright Aaron I got the wild style but
you've got your choice here in the
starter pack of two other characters
I'll let you choose and we'll see who
pops into the game here who you choose
shoes and all what's up wizard you're
shall not use crass language Gandalf
you're very appropriate for all
situations and I appreciate that thank
you so now that we're in the Lego world
what do we start doing beating up Legos
scene of Legos I can shoot like wizard
stuff look look at okay this guy's like
a hundred and three
and he's like doing ninja moves oh yeah
he's got ups for sure oh he's got matter
while Styles more the karate melee style
and you see her she's got that jerky
motion from the lego movie I gotta say
she's like so you got way more
that's one of her special character
skills like that's the thing about these
Lego games is every characters got their
own kind of skill they all can build and
so we're gonna build here is gonna thing
up there and grab this thing oh yeah
boom and now your building is gonna help
you get through the levels and if you're
not sure how to go BAM just smack a
question mark and it turns out oh oh we
need the Dark Knight we need the man the
Batman there is hey what's up we'll stop
flirting I'm tier Chuck dude go come on
he's Batman I'm Batman
I have you taking over Batman I'm Batman
do the bad thing about a ring oh I gotta
take a back grapple yeah he also has
batteries he's got many batteries for
the bearings
alright cool let's go through the sleepy
flow oh no the sleepy flowers we can't
go through there unless we have some
firepower I'm talking Batmobile yeah and
who would be better to ride the
Batmobile than was this this car is
effective I'm telling you pretty
effective it mowing down it's also kind
of a hazard so you definitely want to
stay out of my way sorry Batman
oh gosh [ __ ] off I'm trying to okay she
literally found the one flower I didn't
manage to run over in time so here's the
thing about the starter pack for Lego
dimensions yeah it includes a ton of
different properties I mean we see we
got Batman we've got Lord of the Rings
we've got the Wizard of Oz we've already
encountered and one glance at the box
and you know that there's a lot more in
store that's sort of Lego dimensions
thing is let's just get all of these
different beloved characters and worlds
all together and then Batman is are all
sudden get off his driving the Batmobile
yeah and he's a menace over every single
what you want to do Batman has a Batman
get a taste of your own medicine Batman
ah Gandalf
you shall not
do some cell not slash a reflector piece
of it I'm just going to go ahead and
reboot that drill into not a joke sounds
good
oh dude we got to get the the purple
thing it's on the back of the machine
but it's not on your portal this yet so
this is the deal we want this thing the
Wicked Witch of the West wants this
thing this is gonna go well for us
there's a lot of flying monkeys I don't
that's the music they did like a remix
for the gate I loved it you quit the
flying monkeys it's like a remix of the
flying monkeys on this place makes
cuckoo-land look normal
no we're surrounded by fire we're not on
fire that's a key distinction yeah
there's definitely a difference I should
know I have experience in both in all
forms of being touched by fire or near
fire so we can't just pick up this thing
right now we definitely have to you Oh
God
alright I'm gonna get I'll be locked up
and now the toy pad is blinking because
how do I break out of the chains boom
move wild style to a different part of
the toy padding yo I don't know good
you're ready won't fight another day
ready to go absolutely was full because
he's got the battery battery knocks down
the switch the Batarang knocks out all
kind of things
I got a grapple hook he's super useful
that's true
I just exploded in a pile of studs
Gandalf's other skills I mean he does
have magic straight up which is awesome
you can move stuff around we'll see a
little bit of that and I can also make
this shield so I'm like just chilling oh
and you can make a shield oh yeah buddy
look at that oh she strapped you all
right time to move stuff around
Wow style go for a ride okay we're safe
cool
here we go oh snap Batarang sit her down
you know
that was a little bowling ball noise -
scattering those monkeys alright so the
story continues in chasing down the
Wicked Witch of the West happens but
we're gonna actually jump further ahead
in the story to show you guys something
different that the toy pad can do yeah
and get your optics ready because this
is gonna be a colorful bonanza I sense
great power a man power that will soon
be mine so we've gotten ourselves into a
bit of a tight spot here in the Ninjago
level and currently this guy's just
running circles around us and taking
shots at Gandalf I think it's a little
rude gandalf seems kind of old but as we
all know he can he can handle it yeah he
can hold his own bro
you can these Gandalf here we go oh dang
all right you know that's the best way
to take down super fast enemies is
through Three Stooges gags absolutely if
you can get them with like a box in the
ears or like you know something the
doink in the eyes yep all right now
we're gonna see some of the capabilities
of this toy pad because we all got to
make ourselves this color right you put
your character in the color you're gonna
turn that color but now the yellow is
gone so only Gandalf is yellow we got to
match this kit this card which matches
our toy pads so Gandalf needs to do the
tour okay let's get the Batmobile out of
here want you to take Gandalf around the
horn Gandalf around the horn yep we've
got one part yellow yeah so he's yellow
no just throw yellow down right yeah and
then we got to make Batman red Oh what's
now Oh No yeah good job Batman no we
just learned that from Gandalf
we just need all yellows oh really yeah
man see look at the snake's mouth oh now
wyldstyle and i'm just gonna move wild
cell to the other side boom all yellow
and the toy pad flashes and it's
building done wow that's amazing it's
pretty neat it's kind of a way to make
the toy pad be more than just something
that you know something that looks cool
did you put your toys on it's actually
part of the game that you regularly have
to interact
through that oh yeah what did you just
do what I gave Russ to the snake god I
guess so
and then and then immediately ended him
such his leg oh you know that's just
like huh you build something you break
it down you build it back up again carp
a Lego all right we need the Batmobile
back on the scene oh no I'll do this
silly guy he's wrong real fast
could does he not realize that he's on a
treadmill I think he thinks he's gonna
be able to help them hey you're on a
treadmill buddy don't it work oh dude
that's why you put the safety strap
around your arm yeah stops the whole
load we don't end up a YouTube highlight
you've got your color shenanigans you've
got your teleportation antics and you've
got some elemental powers that you
encounter later on in the story mode
which we've been taking a look at today
but let's talk about the adventure mode
a little bit you get to play an
open-world themed world's talking about
all these characters they get their own
adventure mode you're in middle-earth
you're adventuring around go into hobbit
holes rescuing people going to Gotham as
Batman solving some crimes collecting
some goods we're gonna take a look at
those adventure worlds and more in the
upcoming episodes of inside lego
dimensions and we're gonna show you how
you can upgrade the vehicles you use
in-game and then build entirely new
vehicle models to put on your pack it's
gonna be cool
you